[Music]
[Applause]
i'm pleased to join you today for the
annual ftth conference that for the
first time in two years is happening in
person again
unfortunately i was not able to come to
vienna
but i hope you will make most out of
these two days and this is meeting new
colleagues
learn from various speakers let me start
by saying that we are living in very
particular times
after more than two years of global
pandemic we are confronted today with an
unjustified military aggression against
one
of our neighboring countries
and in both instances
and
with differences
we have seen
how much digital technologies are
essential for working learning and
accessing basic services
but unfortunately they also that the
reign of daily cyber warfare
most importantly digital technologies
have shown the importance of
connectivity
bringing people together
and keeping us
the economy ourself working
independently where you are and
ultimately keeping the society and our
wave or life safe
high-performing digital infrastructure
carry with them a kind of equalizing
dimension
because they have the capacity to render
information communication more available
to a big part of the population
and i must say on top of that
they have the potential to give to our
union
an important competitive added value
if we connect
every our household with fiber
we can make for instance health services
available to everyone advance a deal
service and no matter where they are in
a city
in the middle of
nowhere in a remote island
that's why the commission has set out
very concrete targets for our flagship
digital strategy the digital decade
gcp connectivity for all european
households
and
5g for all populated areas
both targets rely on a massive
fiber development
and all the above of course depend on an
efficient combination of public funding
instruments and private investment
the funding gap is still quite big
especially in rural areas
and to help close it we need to
encourage and support investment in 5g
and fiber
and our president said in an
unprecedented matter
to date i'm very pleased to see that
more than 13 billion
euros
have been invested in the recovery fund
and this
funding has been approved to support the
rollout of digital connectivity networks
in the next three years and especially
in rural regions
and these include
5g
and 5g corridors in 19 member states and
of course we invest in connectivity
the eu will also leverage connectivity
investment through the new coalition
funds invest eu
eib loans
and of course equity instruments and
through the safe digital program the
latter is expected to grant more than 2
billion over 7 years to fund projects
which have a cross-border nature for
instance backbone interconnection
secure and critical digital capacities
global gateways and as well as the 5g
networks in smart communities
the first connected euro facility call
closed last month and the second call is
in the pipeline for the end of this year
we have other success stories which i
would like to share with you
for instance
we have set up the connecting europe
broadband fund
this was launched in 2018
and now is going well beyond the set
target of 500 million of equity
and
so far we have already reached
more than 600 billion in capital
and
30 percent has been raised to
deploy
state of the art network
and most of these projects are in under
service area across the u so it's not
true
that you cannot invest capital in other
areas we have beautiful
fiber projects which are supported by
our equity fund
to maximize the impact of public
investment of course we need a modern
regulatory framework and this is clearly
a precondition
we believe that
the european
electronic communication code
it's really going in this direction and
contains a lot of innovation
for instance the code
has put increased focus on efficient
infrastructure based competition
and this is really the sustainable way
to deliver long-term benefit including
increased network deployment
what we note what we noticed that
there's not enough in terms of
take up of the new instruments
there are new provisions in the code
that directly address the issue of
voluntary cooperation
between network providers
and if cooperation really
can be effectively deployed
then we will see much more investments
regulators have not to be shy in
deploying these new tools
companies have to embrace these new
tools through cooperation through
agreements
we can actually speed up network
deployment it's a new form of
cooperation in regulation between
regulated party regulators that the code
very much sponsors and we would like to
see much more that what we have seen so
far
when it comes to spectrum
we also
tried to deliver a very ambitious
regulatory framework
with the obligation of member state to
make available binary band for fixed and
mobile 5g fixed 5g is really now
taking
quite some traction in some member
states
and we need of course the spectrum to be
made available
and also we have established a very
light regulatory regime for small cell
deployment that's very important for
hybrid forms of 5g and wi-5 and to
facilitate network specifications
thinking for instance at
6g
so far we have not seen a lot of
innovation in this respect and really i
invite
companies to make use of such a
simplified regulatory framework
of course we will work more and more to
make sure
that there are no red tapes that impede
connectivity that's why the new
connectivity infrastructure act will
result in even
better
fight if you like to red tapes
we need to make sure that the
the new connected reactor will replace
the broadband cost reduction directive
and we need to be sure that really fiber
can be quickly deployed everywhere
and where there are burdens
which result from bureaucracy this have
to go
so that's the the purpose of the revised
broadband
uh cost reduction directive
and i hope this would be
an even more effective tool to fight
unnecessary bureaucracy when it comes to
fiber and telegram infrastructure
deployment
i cannot finish my intervention without
saying some words which really come out
of my art
with the outbreak of the war the entire
digital ecosystem
has significantly redirected its effort
to support ukrainian refugees
and i really thank you for this
the commission
has been working closely with eu
telecoms operator and their association
to serve ukrainian telecom equipment
and service needs
and this really in a coordinated way
we have paid particular attention to the
connectivity needs of ukrainian refugees
to keep ukrainian infrastructure
up and running
and i really welcome the joint statement
signed on the 8th of april
both by eu and ukrainian operators
which is a testament of great effort by
both sides
and that's why the commission wants to
go further and explore with you another
stakeholder the possibility to launch a
broad donation initiative
we're really targeting the tech industry
and try to get commitment concrete
commitment
other commitment in support of
ukraine and the ukrainian people
so thank you for the support you have
shown so far
and we count on you for the future
thanks very much
[Music]
you